(Cassandra sniffles)
- [Mark] Cassandra, where
are you from originally?
Where'd you grow up?
- [Cassandra] I grew up
in Long Island, New York.
- [Mark] And you grew up
with both your parents?
- No, I didn't.
Actually, I didn't grow up in Long Island.
I was born in New York,
but I grew up in Michigan.
My first, the story they
used to tell about me,
my first memory was coming to find out
my dad married my mom,
she was pregnant with another man's kid,
so I'm technically the first born.
The story goes, my dad was in the Navy.
He's a nuclear physicist, he
was on nuclear submarines.
My mother must've been beautiful.
The only thing I've been
told about her, though,
is that she was stacked.
But he walked away from a full
scholarship to Notre Dame.
Anyway,
I guess when he got off,
being away for a few months,
he came to my mother's mother's house,
with my mom on his arm and
my baby sister, Monique,
who was three months old.
His parents already had
my older sister, Dana,
and said, "Mom, she cheated on me."
And he left, and my mom kept me.
About a year-and-a-half later,
my grandparents said I was
dropped off on their doorstep
in a dirty diaper with a
man's shirt on and no shoes
in the middle of winter.
And we had steak for dinner that night.
And four hours later, we had dessert.
I had something in my mouth.
I had saved all my chewed up meat,
because I said I wanted to eat later.
I think that's the saddest
fucking story I ever heard.
But they would laugh about it
and tell it at the dinner table.
I felt like the odd man out.
I feel ...
I feel guilty kind of
talking about it, you know,
because I feel like,
I feel guilty when talking
about why I feel guilty.
But I feel like our society covets
a level of attractiveness or slenderness
and being the middle child.
Also, I got special
treatment from strangers.
And my dad, he married my
stepmother when we were,
when I was six.
And he married her basically
to take care of his problem,
which was the three of
us, me and my two sisters.
And moved us to Long Island.
And I remember
I was very angry at my
grandparents' house.
And I kind of digress,
but after I got there,
every day my grandma would tell me,
"Your mom's not coming back.
"She doesn't love you."
And when my dad would
come home at dinner time,
I had to say that my mom didn't love me,
and she wasn't coming back,
and I refused to say it.
So I had to go to bed without dinner,
and I would get a spanking.
We did this for about two years.
Obviously not a good alliance to have.
She never did come back.
So I don't know what was worse,
like the screaming for her in my head
or the silence where I forgot she existed.
Because silence has a sound, too.
But when we moved to Long Island,
Dana and Monique, they
were so traumatized,
because my dad's parents
were the only parents they had known.
And I remember thinking to myself
how lucky I was that grandma
and grandpa didn't love me,
because, I mean,
whether it was true or not doesn't matter.
That was my feelings
about it, but I felt ...
(siren wailing)
- [Mark] Give it a sec,
let's let this siren go by.
- Am I talking too much?
(horn honking)
Am I saying too much?
- [Mark] No, no, you're perfect.
No, I just, I wanted
to let the siren go by,
because it just drowns out
whatever you're gonna say.
So you were saying.
- I remember thinking that,
and my older sister Monique
started wetting the bed,
and she would just wake up from a nap
and come down to the kitchen and she'd be,
tears would just be
streaming down her eyes,
and she didn't even know she was crying.
And that was when my
stepmom started hitting us.
She would call us disgusting.
And she would withhold
food as a punishment.
So we would eat food out of the trash.
So he were called liars and thieves
when she would catch us.
There's a line from a song where he says,
"The reasons all have run away
but the feeling never did."
So that feeling of being
guilty and unwanted,
but when we were in Long Island,
about two weeks, I had a dream
about a guardian angel
and his name was Michael.
And he said that I
wouldn't meet him again,
but that I had other guardian angels
and my job was to take
care of my two sisters.
And that bad things were
gonna happen to me in my life.
And he wanted to apologize for that,
but said that God didn't
create us to make,
to make us love him.
So there were certain things
he could control and certain
things that he couldn't.
It was very vivid.
I woke up my sister and told her about it.
And oddly enough,
one of the last things my
mother ever said to me was,
"Just remember Cassie, God
shrink-wrapped your heart.
"They can take everything else.
"And men will touch you, but
God shrink-wrapped your heart."
So.
I don't know.
During that period of time
I didn't know my dad that well.
And I wish I had.
But I remember my stepmother
went back to Michigan
for a couple of days and my
father was left to care for us.
Now he had me when he was 20.
So you can imagine he was a young man.
And he would have been,
what, 25 at this time?
But we were playing on the floor.
It was one of the first times
I really spent time with him alone.
And I remember he pinched me so hard
that it left like a blood blister.
I felt so offended.
It was such a strange thing.
It's a strange story to tell.
But after that, I kind
of stayed away from him.
We got hit every day.
My step mom started having her own kids.
And Dana and Monique were
increasingly called fat and ugly.
We weren't allowed to go
in the store with her,
because we were, she was too
beautiful to have children
like us or as old as us.
And when we moved back to Michigan.
I try not,
I always say that I,
and I'm not mad, but I
don't think about it.
I won't think about it
longer than five seconds.
My two sisters, they hate
and they hate beautifully.
They're married.
They have good lives.
My older sister has two master's degrees.
My younger sister got accepted
to all these amazing colleges.
But it's a daily thing where
they speak about our childhood
and blame them singularly.
That doesn't work for me.
I find it's hard to sustain.
If I think about it longer than 30 seconds
the rage is so intense.
I just, I think, I can't handle it.
You know, I was 13-and-a-half.
My dad was arrested for child abuse
against me specifically.
And you know, my stepmother had been the,
she broke my older
sister's nose four times.
Food was always withheld as a punishment.
I used to have to take my clothes off
before I left for school
and when I came back.
I mean, she would physically put
her fingers inside me to see
if I had taken, was
bringing anything home.
I got a candy bar wrapper or ...
So my father took her to trial.
That day they estimated
he hit me about 60 times
with the buckle end of a belt,
and then an hour-and-a-half
went by and he was still mad.
So he did it another 50
times, shattered my tailbone.
That night my clothes scabbed to me,
but I didn't cry
until I collapsed on the floor and said,
"Please don't hit me again."
It's just so embarrassing.
And he said, "I'm gonna hit you
"like this every day
that you're grounded."
So I ran away that night
and I went to school for the first time,
I went to school the next day.
I never missed a day of school.
My principal said, "You're
not allowed to be here."
He had called the police.
I was so terrified.
He said I'd get in so much trouble.
They were gonna relinquish me to him,
but a female teacher
demanded a female officer.
I didn't make a statement.
I never told, but the
injuries spoke for themselves.
He took it to trial.
The day of the trial he
asked me to lie for him.
They ended up keeping me in the house.
They sent me to live with
my grandfather who said
I was a whore and couldn't stay there.
And, but the day of the trial,
in the cafeteria the family's on one side,
me and him are on the other.
And he says,
how do I feel about
destroying everybody's life?
And that he was gonna go to jail?
And I said, "How does it
feel to have your freedom
"in the hands of somebody that
you said was so worthless?"
That's one of the things
I'm most proud of,
that I had the wherewithal
to know to say that.
If I ever feel bad, I can remember that.
And I did lie for him.
(sirens wailing)
- [Mark] Just let the siren go by.
Yep, they stopped.
- One thing though, I had a
severe stuttering problem.
It started when I was about six years old.
Very, very bad.
Most people don't know this about me.
Really bad.
Every word, duh-duh-duh.
It was incapacitating.
And when I had to, this is
when they put me on the stand,
I couldn't say my name.
Now as an adult, I go by Cassandra,
but I couldn't say Cassandra.
I could only say Cassie
and I was supposed to state
my full name for the court.
And the judge was a female.
And she said,
"I can't believe you're
gonna put her through this.
"Quietly just accept the plea bargain."
But I did lie for him
and I left the next day.
I've never been back.
But after I left ...
- [Mark] Just let this go by.
- I have to say, I had a social worker.
Can I say her name?
Janine McFarlane.
- [Mark] Sure.
- She was so amazing.
This is in Detroit, you know?
And she found me, Janine found me,
until I was 30 years old and
she would send me a gift.
I mean, we're talking,
she showed up in like three
carat diamond earrings
and a mink coat and drove a Mercedes.
Very unusual.
When I was 15 I was bullied
really bad in school.
Really, really bad.
In fact, I came to a
point before the trial
where I stopped seeing colors.
I was really scared.
I was left for dead in
the snow by two girls.
They put cigarettes out on me.
I would say the quickest
way to sober me up
is put me in a room with fucked up people.
The worst thing I could think of to do
to say I was upset was smoke cigarettes,
but I remember I grew up in
a good neighborhood, if you will,
But the kids who were on the
wrong side of the tracks,
their parents didn't ask,
"Why is this girl here on a school night?"
But I have no idea why I got so fortunate.
I knew there were drugs all around,
but I didn't see them and
I stayed away from them.
But somebody's trashy
mother called somebody's,
some of these girls, girl,
that I was with this boy.
And I had yet to even
get that far with a boy.
But a group of people came
and three girls beat me up.
And they took all my clothes,
put cigarettes out on me.
When I came to, they said,
"The street's that way."
I knocked on seven doors.
It was about 7:30 at night
before someone opened the door.
- [Mark] How old were you?
- 15.
And I just remember coming
in and out of consciousness,
bleeding all over this,
yeah, it was a young couple,
all over their bathroom.
And I kept saying, "I'm
really not white trash."
And then my dad was in the doorway.
I said, "How did you know who my dad was?"
And they said, "You told us."
After they put me back in the house,
no one was allowed to call me Cassie,
everybody had to call me Stupid.
I was no longer a part of the family.
The hitting stopped,
but it was on, it was a war.
And Dana and Monique,
they got it the worst.
Dana got it really bad.
I'd been beat up.
I remember, my parents
rarely ever went out,
but the Christmas cookie story.
They went out during the holidays once
and we never had house keys,
we were not allowed to open the fridge
or touch the television
or the radio, nothing.
We didn't have keys to the house,
because remember we
were liars and thieves,
we might eat food.
So we're waiting in the garage,
when we come home from school
and on the door to the garage
leading into the house is,
"Use guys."
My stepmother would use that word.
"Better get your story straight.
"There were 32 Christmas cookies.
"And then when we got home
last night, there were 22.
"Somebody's gonna get it.
"You better, whoever did it,
you know, better step forth."
Dana starts wailing like, "Oh God!"
You know?
And I remember saying, "Okay, okay.
"It's almost like Ferris
Bueller's day off, right?
"I'll take the heat."
My stepmother, that Air
Star minivan pulls up.
She doesn't ask who did it.
She just gets out.
She grabs Dana by the hair
and takes her to the kitchen.
And she starts banging her
head against the stove.
I'm terrified.
And that's when I realized,
it didn't have to do with
the Christmas cookies.
It was just rage,
she wanted to take it out on anyone.
I remember running to
the phone and saying,
I thought she was going to kill Dana,
"I'm gonna call 911!"
My stepmother just grabbed the phone
out of my hand and hit me over
the head with it and said,
"You're not calling anyone."
That was a valuable lesson.
My two sisters,
no one grows up wanting to be a liar
or a drug addict or promiscuous.
But I don't, I mean, I feel fortunate.
I learned very early on that,
the goalposts were constantly changing.
And I was taught how to be a good liar.
I likened my stepmother to,
I got big ogre.
And you could see when
the rage would start.
"Who was in the refrigerator,
"or who didn't take out the trash?"
If you went to the
bathroom or left number two
you'd have to go into the bathroom
and stand there until
someone said, "Who did it?"
For hours, like why not
just flush the toilet?
I mean, I don't know
what any of this means.
I've never revisited this.
But if you lied to my stepmother
then the momentum of the
punch wouldn't be as,
it wouldn't hurt as bad.
If you were like, "Look over there."
You know?
It would confuse her almost.
So.
And if you recall,
I had a different father
than my older sister, Dana.
There's a picture of us,
even though we're almost,
Dana, my older sister is
almost exactly a year older
and my little one, almost
exactly a year younger.
And we all shared a room.
But in this photograph,
I am up to Dana's shoulder
and she has her arm around me.
Dana was much larger than me,
but more of a gentle soul and
more fearful, anxiety ridden.
I would say when, and
Dana would go for her.
We'd say, "Dana, hit her back."
We just weren't big enough.
You know?
Dana was like 5'11.
She'd be terrifying today.
But what was I saying?
- [Mark] You mentioned earlier
on before we started cameras,
that you were molested at some point?
- Yes.
After I left home after the trial,
I didn't have a winter coat
and I would sit in the
breezeway of this restaurant.
After about a month a man
gave me a roll of dimes
and said to call someone.
I looked in the yellow pages for my aunt,
and I remember my mother's maiden name.
And I found her sister
who came and picked me up.
The first thing she asked was
"What kind of cigarettes do you smoke?"
And I hadn't really learned how to inhale,
but I just looked down and
she smoked Virginia Slims.
And as I said, "I smoke those."
She said, "What a coincidence."
And went and got me a pack.
They were drug addicts.
- [Mark] How old were you?
- Almost 16, 15-and-a-half.
- [Mark] Okay.
- She had a son, he was 20 years older.
He was my cousin, I never met him,
but she put me in his bedroom.
I thought she didn't know.
But now I realize she
put me in his bedroom
so he'd come home with the drugs.
And it was, "You do, as we
do, or you don't stay here."
I mean, it's hard to express.
It's hard.
It's hard to draw a picture,
but we had no furniture,
much like crackheads.
My cousin was a gaffer.
So I always slept on the floor.
We had a spool as our coffee
table and director's chairs.
And then we had a chalkboard
to keep track of anybody who double toked.
This is pot.
We had a SWAT team come
into her house actually.
But that first night that I was there
on the floor in his bedroom,
my cousin got out of his bed
and laid down next to me behind me.
I still had never, I mean,
the most I had done was kiss a boy.
So.
He took my choice to choose.
He didn't, he didn't do it that night.
He was ...
As far as predators
go, he made it seem ...
I lie to myself as if I
was a participant in it.
It changes things.
This is really hard for me to talk about.
And it's really scary.
I guess it creates certain
proclivities in your life.
I'm not gonna explain what that means,
but I'm sure you can look up the word.
- [Mark] Okay, you don't want
to talk about it, all right.
- I guess, I just, he took
what he took and I didn't want
to be, to sit at that bus stop
like a survivor of being molested.
So I just told myself some story.
But then I was off to the races,
I became a pot addict.
That's an underrated addiction.
I smoked pot every day for five years.
I'll tell you what.
And like I said, God was my only friend.
So I cried myself to sleep
for maybe two years
wanting to get out and ...
Could we take a break?
- [Mark] Sure.
- Sorry.
Okay, I guess, I didn't tell my aunt.
I felt like that, you
know, just to protect her.
I hadn't smoked pot before.
And I remember telling a girl next door
after two weeks of being there,
"I can't keep doing this."
You know?
Come to find out my aunt
had taken my dad to court
and she was getting money from him.
She never so much as bought
me a pair of underwear.
She, at first she told me,
"You're not going to school anymore.
"You're gonna watch Dylan."
Which is my cousin's son, who was seven.
I went, we got evicted from every place.
So went from an upscale neighborhood to
basically the Skid Row of Michigan.
We ended up in Redford Union, Eight Mile.
There was a shower downstairs
in one of the places that we rented.
It was an unfinished basement,
and I'll never forget this.
I came downstairs and
I hear my little cousin
who's eight years old
saying, sobbing, going,
"Why me, God, why me?"
In the shower.
I did, prior to her
pulling me out of school.
I did end up going to high school
for about three weeks at a place,
at a high school called
Redford Union on Eight Mile.
Yes, where Eminem hails from.
And two events happened.
I ended up meeting the
cutest boy in school
whose girlfriend was on a family vacation,
but no one thought to tell me.
And the principal there,
he had me in his office
and he asked me to
unbutton my shirt for him.
And that stayed with me forever
for a number of reasons.
That wasn't in my file anything about me,
about sexual abuse.
How did he know that I wouldn't tell?
From then on I felt like everybody knew,
like I was wearing a scarlet letter.
Everybody knew that I was being molested.
And ...
This is only one of the few times
in my life I've ever vocalized that
or allowed myself to.
I'm a very compartmentalized person.
And I don't consider myself a liar.
And if I ever do lie, it's because I'm,
I've probably lied to myself as well.
But how could he have
known I wouldn't tell?
And did I comply?
Yes.
I found power from it in a way.
On the flip side,
the downside was a billion miles deep,
but after ...
I felt like I had no choice, so I made it,
I lied to myself as if
I did in the moment.
And what I was telling myself was,
"So dad, you said I was so worthless.
"Well, guess what?
"I can make this person risk everything.
"So how worthless am I
"if I can bring this
person to their knees?"
Whatever somebody thinks of that
is neither here nor there.
It is what it is
as far as then.
And I maybe only know
this now, looking back
but after Mauritzio,
his girlfriend got back,
we were living of course, renting a place
made out of Kleenex and spit.
There was maybe 40 girls
outside calling for my head.
Terrifying.
So, no, I never went back
to school after that.
But I did have one friend, Tamara,
who worked at Taco Bell.
Shortly thereafter the SWAT
team came into our house.
My cousin Dylan was selling
pot out of the house.
My aunt would send me with
him to the tip of Florida,
where we would drive there
and back in three days.
He would put the bricks of
marijuana above the engine.
He would use a gaffers blanket.
Yeah, so when the SWAT team came in,
you know, "Get down, get down, get down!"
His girlfriend, Tamara,
she was about 350 pounds
and she worked at Taco Bell.
The police kept calling
her the Big Burrito.
She's like, she wasn't gonna get down,
but they took us all to jail
and then they proceeded to tell me that
if I didn't buy drugs from three people
three times with marked money,
I was gonna go to prison.
They had photographs
of me opening the door.
Wow, this is so embarrassing.
I, when I was 13-and-a-half,
when ninth grade first started,
you were allowed to
leave campus for school.
And there was this man, Todd Caribbean.
He was probably 36 years old,
but he would hang outside the pizza place.
And some of my girlfriends knew him.
Of course the girls from the
wrong side of the tracks.
But he, when I would run away from home,
he would put me in a hotel room.
But so when I had to buy
these drugs with marked money,
I bought drugs from friends of his
that weren't really drug dealers.
And I really only bought
two times from one person.
Shortly thereafter, Todd,
I run into Todd again,
he takes me to a party.
And we start playing quarter
bounce around seven o'clock,
by eight I was extremely inebriated
and I was taken upstairs and gang raped.
When he came in the bedroom,
they had me tied up.
He asked me about his friend
whose house the police came into
and how it was right after I
asked him to sell me drugs.
And then he walked out of the door.
I remember I kept coming
in and out of reality
and I was begging them to stop.
There maybe were eight or 10 college guys.
One of the boy's sisters
comes in and sees this
and gets hysterical.
She puts me in the shower
and I was just ashamed to be alive.
I was ashamed.
I guess I was ashamed that,
I was ashamed for myself.
Ashamed that I was there,
that I was a person.
Years later.
Let me try to get this succinct.
My aunt, right?
She was an executive secretary.
So as we got evicted from all these places
she would get a job as
an executive secretary.
She'd been married eight times.
So the gentlemen that she
had been with previous,
they actually had a home
that was in Town and Country
but he ended up leaving
her for her best friend
who could still have children.
So she had this wardrobe,
but I guess she was telling
her other men she works with
she had a daughter and
she needed assistance.
And maybe they would like
to go on a date with me.
I didn't quite understand it.
I know it sounds like a dichotomy.
I feel so blessed,
but (indistinct)
takes me to a hotel room
and says, "I can't do this."
And I say, "Do what?"
And he tells me how my
aunt has insinuated fully
that he could have sex with me
for the $800 that he gave her
to help us with our rent money.
I don't even know what
to think about this now.
I've never repeated that.
My voice is, I've never heard those words.
And I feel strange.
I guess I can't put anything into it.
I met one of these men.
I never did have sex
with any of these men.
And I blocked out a lot of it.
To me, it was just a handful.
One of these men took
me to his friend's house
in a place called Bloomfield Hills,
which was the Bel Air of Michigan.
His friend had a hot tub where
everybody had to take their clothes off.
This person was married
and owned the company where
my aunt was the executive secretary.
So I guess he wanted to see me naked,
but his friend, his name was Michael.
He was 31 years old, nice Jewish boy.
My size.
And me and him ...
He really liked me.
He was single.
And I liked him too.
So he asked if he could
take me out on a date.
So we started going out.
I never said anything about
what was happening at our
house and he never asked.
He ...
On one of our, I remember
like our third date,
he takes me to his home.
I had never seen anything so beautiful.
And mind you, I had grown
up in a nice neighborhood,
but it had been two years
that I had been, you know,
in the Skid Row of Michigan.
And if you can imagine
driving down a Boulevard,
take here in California,
for example, in Los Angeles,
imagine driving down Sunset Boulevard,
imagine Sunset and Alvarado.
Which is even not the best example,
but take Sunset all the
way past the Bel Air Hotel,
how everything gets green and opens up.
And we take that drive with him,
it was the most beautiful thing
I've ever seen in my whole life.
So beautiful.
I remembered that there was a world again,
but he made me his special pasta dish,
I guess, in the broccoli
he had made a smiley face.
Two eyes and a smile out of broccoli,
but I just started eating, first thing.
And I remember he was so offended and hurt
that I hadn't waited to
see the smile in the pasta.
There's gotta be some
answer there that, right?
But after dinner I took off my clothes
and I'm trying to have sex with him.
And he was really freaked out.
I don't know why I'm mentioning this,
but it was significant,
because it just speaks
to his character, like,
"Slow down, that wasn't
what he wanted to do."
You know?
And so we didn't.
Mind you, he was the first person that
I had tried to do that with
since I was gang raped,
that I kind of, I'm going backwards a bit,
but that morning when I woke
up with throw-up in my hair
and I was in the shower
and I swore I would never
have sex with anyone again.
And I fought off my cousin after that.
So things were coming
to a head, a real head.
Going back to Michael.
He started taking me to hippy festivals
and he got me to drop acid with him,
which I would never take back,
I would never do it again,
but I would never take that back.
I did it maybe six or seven times.
And I've been told that it bridges
the conscious to the subconscious.
And my experience, I
didn't see pink elephants,
but I saw how beautiful the world was.
And just how, the way I grew
up was just no way to live.
And there was something more.
That said, I know that
Michael knew a lot more,
and he never asked and I never told.
But one day after going to a wedding,
and we had been drinking
and the night before we had taken acid,
I come home to get
changed for another event
that we're gonna go to.
And my cousin is, at this point
he's now obsessed with me.
Calling me a whore and a slut and a bimbo.
This is going on every day.
He starts, he's violent, following me.
His advances had become
very, very violent,
trying to rape me.
And I just walked out the door
and walked all the way to Michael's house.
And he opens the door and he said,
"You're not gonna leave,
you're not leaving,
"you're here to stay, right?"
He just knew and I said, "Yes."
And we made a bowl of mashed potatoes.
And we were so nervous.
We sat on the counter cross legged
and ate the mashed potatoes.
And then we went up across the street.
There was this beautiful school
and there was a swing set.
We sat on a swing set
and the sun was setting
and it was the most
beautiful day I'd ever seen.
I thought, "This is the
first day of my life.
"No one's ever gonna hit me again.
"No one's ever gonna touch me again.
"No one's ever gonna call
me a name, it's over now.
"It's finally over."
It was one of the greatest
moments of my life.
It's where I'd like to be buried.
So that was my first home.
And it lasted maybe two-and-a-half years.
And that's where I quit smoking pot.
Like I say, I cried myself
to sleep for two years.
I carried that addiction
into that relationship.
My little sister called.
Monique.
Ah, Monique.
So Monique is getting
written up in the newspaper
and living at grandpa's,
because remember, I was a whore,
I couldn't live at grandpa's.
I'm getting raped violently
at night by my cousin.
Monique called me to tell me that
she's gotten into the AmeriCorps,
the domesticated Peace Corps.
I say, "Monique, will you come
see me before you go away?"
She says, "Cassie, I have a life."
And I hung up the phone
and I looked around me
and I thought, "God doesn't exist.
"I've been talking to
no one this whole time.
"There's no one."
And I just panicked.
I had my first panic attack
and I ended up at the hospital.
Well, I started getting anxiety
attacks every single day.
I end up at the hospital.
They offered me a Xanax.
And I had taken acid.
So it was January the third, 1997.
But so new year's eve
I had, and I thought,
"This is an acid flashback, this is it.
"You know, I'm fucked for life."
I went to four therapists,
and of course the most expensive one.
I'm always gonna remember his name, Stan.
Stan, something or other.
He said, "Are you hearing voices, kid?"
I said, "No."
He said, "Did you feel like
driving into oncoming traffic?"
I said, "No."
He said, "You're gonna be fine."
The one before him said, "Well."
I said, "Michael smoked ... "
I had just smoked pot previous
to hanging up the phone.
And I said to her, "Well,
Michael smoked the same pot too."
Because I thought maybe it
was laced with something.
She said, "Well, if you
drink from a carton of milk
"only one person's gonna get
the swallow with the spider."
I remember calling her
up later telling her
how irresponsible that statement was.
The reason for a lot of my worry was,
it turns out my mother was
a paranoid schizophrenic.
But it turns out, turns out
that this diagnosis from
the state to get money.
So who really knows
if she's was really a
paranoid schizophrenic?
And they can't test for schizophrenia.
Shows up between the ages of 19 and 22.
So I've never been diagnosed
as crazy, unfortunately.
I was ready to get married.
For nine years I had slept with three men.
And I remember being in Barney's.
This will bring us up to, closer to,
as I said, yes, it was a
black Amex, my name on it.
(indistinct).
And I've never said I love you for money.
And I couldn't find one thing to buy.
So ...
Growing up, we didn't have any,
you couldn't have any heroes.
We weren't allowed to
listen to music or touch the television.
You know, this is in
Michigan, you're in a suburb.
Really, all I wanted to do is be a lady.
I read every Miss Manners book.
I wanted to be a lady.
I wanted to play the piano
and I wanted to run track.
Just on kind of like a side note.
After, I was refused piano lessons,
but all three of those boyfriends
they all played the piano
and each one had one in their home.
And I never once sat down and played it.
I ended the relationship with Mark.
I gave him back the ring.
It was a five carat diamond.
People thought I was crazy.
The only thing any of the men I've loved
have had in common is
they've all pulled themselves
up by their bootstraps.
But I felt like for some reason,
if I married him I'd
be dead in six months.
And I wasn't even a drug addict yet.
Nine months after the first panic attack,
and I was getting them every day,
I met my second boyfriend
who was in a rock band
and he was into his 25th year of being
a cocaine addict and an alcoholic.
And I had my first drink with him,
by the third one I stopped,
my heart stopped pounding
and I started drinking
and I drank every day for eight years.
So.
It was very bad.
I had been written off
for dead many times.
And in the end, I ended up with a DUI.
My liver was shutting down.
I passed the field test,
but I blew over a point two.
They took me straight to the hospital.
And I guess quitting drinking is
one of the only things that can kill you.
You can die from that.
And I was at that point.
So I begged a check
from my ex fiance to see
a foremost pharma psychiatrist.
I do not know why our
meeting went the way it did,
but when I got to his office,
and I was all very
straight-laced, buttoned up.
He said, "Sit anywhere."
Maybe he didn't like where I chose to sit,
but I said, "You know, I
can't see myself drinking,
"but if I do, I'm very
concerned about having seizures.
"What, if anything, can you
give me to prevent that?"
He said, "Well, first of all
"I think you need a 12 step program.
"And secondly, I think
you sexualize situations
"and probably always will."
Even as I speak it, I
can hardly believe it.
What is that?
It took me a decade-and-a-half
to convince myself that,
"No one can tell that you
were molested, Cassie.
"You know, it's just in your head."
The two or three people I
ever told about it, you know,
had close, close friends,
had convinced me of the same.
And I was just starting to kind
of move forward in my life.
And that kind of tore all that down.
But right now, this conversation
is neither here nor there.
About two months later,
I finished everything I
needed to do for the DUI.
Mind you, the classes
were at 8:30 at night
and that was my morning.
Except going to the 15 AA meetings,
I never even heard of that place,
but I ended up on a mattress.
I went out every night for eight years.
I wake up on a mattress on the floor
and it's three o'clock in the morning.
The room is so dark.
I can't even see my
hand in front of my face
and there was no alcohol in the house.
And I had the DTs.
I'm shaking, I'm sweating.
You know, my mind knows it's not real,
but I can feel and see the devil.
I say to this other body
next to me in the dark,
"I think I'm gonna have
to go to the hospital."
And they said, "Well, you're walking."
And all of a sudden I heard
this voice in my ear saying,
"Cassie, Cassie just quit."
And it was like they were
speaking another language.
"Just quit."
Like, I never heard those
two words ever before.
And this feeling of calm came over me.
And I said to this other
human in the darkness,
"I think I'm gonna go to
that AAAA place tomorrow."
And they said, "Well, you're going alone."
I looked it up the next day.
And I went, and I took the burning desire.
And I said, "Yes, some
would say I'm an alcoholic."
Because in the beginning
of the meeting they ask,
"Are you an alcoholic?"
And I didn't respond.
But at the end I said, "Yes, I am."
And I didn't drink again for four years.
I used to think God wants me bad.
Yeah, I did that,
then I decided to pick
up a cocaine addiction.
I had been a cocaine
addict earlier in my life
from one of the times
when my aunt needed money
she sold me to the guy across the hall.
He was probably in his first,
in his second decade as
a serious coke addict.
And I remember somebody
moving into the complex
who turned out to be, his name was Randy.
Randy turned out.
He was an attorney that
had been disbarred.
So he became a commercial real estate,
no, industrial law, something like that.
But somebody moved into the complex
whom he went to college with.
His wife had just left him.
And I remember him taking
his first line of coke
since college, six months
later he's carpet farming.
He's in the carpet looking
for pieces of cocaine,
which I now know he was looking for crack.
And I had Michael, that first boyfriend,
buy some cocaine for us.
And he had never done cocaine.
We were getting it every other day
for the first three months.
And I remember him looking up
at me after snorting a line
off of that Radiohead CD, Pablo Honey
and asking me, "Do I look cool?"
And I said, "We're
never doing coke again."
'Cause I remember that guy
crawling around on the carpet.
I didn't want that kind
of blood on my hands.
But after quitting the drinking
I had a long way back.
And I was barely there when
I got this pretty big job.
And everyone thought I
was gonna fail at it.
Around the same time a neighbor asked me
if I knew where to get some cocaine.
And I called a friend and
found out who delivered.
And I decided to get myself a gram.
Cocaine's an anesthetic.
So I knew everything that was
happening, but I felt nothing.
And that's what I wanted.
During that period of time
the inside of my nose fell out.
So I was snorting about two grams a day,
which went up to an eight ball.
And for about a month,
I couldn't even breathe.
I couldn't get more coke up my nose.
Until one day something
came out of my nose
and it was a chunk of
cartilage, basically.
This is terrifying.
I couldn't stop snorting
and my nose was falling out.
A friend of mine, a DJ named Bizo
went deaf and blind from his cocaine use.
I didn't,
also during the entire
time that I'm a coke addict
I continued to go to AA meetings.
I go late, I leave early.
I sit in the back and say nothing.
Not wanting to accept that I'm gonna be
a cocaine addict always.
So, I just felt so isolated, so alone.
And I got a serious sinus infection,
and I called my gynecologist,
because he knew about my weight loss.
And I flew back from San Francisco to,
I was there for work, to see a specialist
who never used the word cocaine, but said,
"You need to stop the
medication immediately."
And removed the inside of my nose.
Okay, I'm just gonna say it.
Around that time I met somebody,
and it was a gated community in Calabasas.
I was helping, he was recording an album.
He had a giant bowl with all
these white chunks in it.
And he said, "This isn't really ..."
I hate the word crack.
Why do they say crack
is a poor man's drug?
This stuff, I mean, so basically,
you take the stuff you get, right?
And then you cook it.
And then you only end up with half.
I'm telling you.
He smoked from a bong.
I'll just say
I would have some help from
some gentlemen friends.
And some,
we'll just stick to the
straight and narrow on this.
Somebody introduced me
to him in the capacity of
maybe we would hit it off to
enjoy an evening together.
And I get to his home
and he's in a bathrobe.
He's got cash in one
pocket, like Scarface,
and gun in the other.
And there's all these girls
around with really bad skin.
There's contractors there
that are doing something,
putting swirly cues on his windows.
You know, a lot happening,
what I now know is a
real crack head trait.
Not because I'm a crack head or allegedly.
I'm sorry, this is really uncomfortable.
It's not like I lie, but by omission.
But if you don't tell the truth,
if you don't know where you stand,
you don't know where you'll land, right?
But yeah, this madam,
if you will, says, she,
this is the third person
that I ever met through her.
And she says, "Oh, you know,
don't expect, you know,
"he's a party person, $100, $200."
And we get there and he
asked me, "How much?"
I said, "$1,000."
And he looks at me up and down.
He says, "Okay."
He has her leave and closes the door.
And then he says, "You're
not really a ho, are you?"
And I was so embarrassed.
I never heard anybody like use that word
or like speak to me in that way.
You know?
I mean, like I said, I
lie to myself, you know?
I was always arguing with my best friend,
"There's a difference between
"hamburger meat and filet mignon."
And he says, "Prostitution
is prostitution."
I guess I've come a long way
that I can even say that word.
This is an unmarried guy.
I mean, I carry around
so much shame about that.
That's a whole other story.
But that's how I learned about crack.
And he was, but his first
statement was, "This isn't crack.
"This is cocaine and I cook it."
So it's cocaine, but isn't that crack?
But anyway, we smoked from a bong.
And he didn't have any
powder I could snort.
It took me about a year before I started
actually buying crack.
I resent you for getting me to say it.
No one got me to say it.
My own free will.
I only had one cocaine dealer.
And he said to me, "I can get you hard."
He never used the word
crack, just hard cocaine.
And I mean, I guess in some
ways you could look at it like
a blessing, because even if
I finally stopped snorting,
cartilage still kept falling,
still kept coming out of my nose.
I could put a finger
all the way in the back
and it would take a week for
whatever it was to come out.
Wow.
Wow, wow, wow.
But yeah,
so I started smoking crack.
And I hid it from people,
intuitively I needed
to hide it from people
around that time, you know?
I had too much money and too much grief.
Pretty much self-indulgent
grief over some other things.
So my dealer leaves a gram of heroin over.
Shows me how to smoke it
although he didn't smoke it.
And you know, I'll be darned if I didn't,
it's really not that easy when
you first start chasing the dragon.
You've gotta roll up the tinfoil foil,
you know, you've gotta kind
of point the tinfoil this way.
I'm telling you, it's kind of difficult.
But I got the hang of it and
just took on another addiction.
So I was smoking two
grams of heroin a day.
Besides the crack and then I found that
bongs were not easy to transport.
One day, my regular dealer is out of town.
So we send somebody over
who comes with 30 packages
all wrapped up in little squares.
And I think, "Is what I'm gonna become?
"Like what kind of drugs are you on
"that you wrap these things
up in little squares?
"What am I supposed to do with this?"
I know now that's a dub,
but that freaked me out so badly.
I called my best friend.
I gave him a number
of somebody in AA and said,
"This is what's been happening.
"I need to check myself in somewhere."
Because I needed to want to want to quit.
And in six hours I found
myself in this bougie rehab.
I would say, let's bring this to today.
If I'm honest, okay.
I've always, I smoke heroin.
I do cocaine.
The last AA meeting I went to,
which was seven years ago.
I took the burning desire and said,
"I know you got to have 24
hours before you can share,
"but it's been five years.
"So I'm just gonna say, you know,
"I can't stop doing drugs
"and my nose is falling out.
"In my walk-in closet, that's
where I would go to try to ...
"(indistinct)
"It was so loud trying to blow my nose
"or get whatever it was in there out.
"And I think I'm gonna die."
And I just left.
Oh, I think I did say, "You
people set the bar so low
"you could trip over it."
The last conversation I
had with my little sister
she asked me how I wanted to be buried.
She's never even seen me do these drugs.
I started, anyway.
You know, I always thought
that if I ever asked for help
that it would be there,
that I'd been paying into that.
I never cried wolf.
And it's kind of like seeing
a fire extinguisher every day.
And not only when you break the glass
do you realize that it's empty,
it's not even a real fire extinguisher.
It's like a blow up fire extinguisher.
When I was in, had been an alcoholic
I sought out help for that,
looking for a facility.
They were quoting me $30,000, $50,000.
And now mind you, it was a
little bit of a different time.
And also you need round the clock care.
So I didn't know anything about
some place that was free or
something of that nature.
And I thought every rehab was that,
I didn't know it was mostly
indigenous to just alcohol.
So I go to this rehab.
It was a horrible experience.
One of the facilitators calling
me in her office and saying,
"You know, if you want to dress
like that every single day,
"you know, that's fine.
"But if you just want
to be seen as you know,
"so when it's, you know, just shallow
"and is just good for nothing
but being on somebody's arm.
"I mean, that's fine, that's up to you.
"You know, just because we don't have
"600 thread count sheets here
"doesn't mean that we can't help you."
And I am so ...
I was sitting there.
I'm so exhausted.
I didn't ...
This is what this woman is saying to me.
You know?
I mean, I called in maybe
the only favor I ever had
in my life to get this like $32,000
to get to this place to realize
I'm the only one that paid any money
and they have these scholarships
and they're also charging my
insurance $10,000 a month.
And she's talking to me
about thread count on sheets.
Come to find out that
the guy, Chris Bathum,
was arrested three years later for
possession and insurance fraud.
Yeah.
I ended up losing two Mac computers
and my iPhone and my hard drive.
Some little boy toy I had
been fooling around with
put a security pin on my phone.
So that payment couldn't
be accepted for my phone.
And I was there one day prior to 90.
So I lost the phone
number I had for 15 years.
I think I had mentioned a little bit
about having had mentors or gentlemen that
helped greatly financially in my life.
So the loss of me not
being able to call out,
my phone not being able to call in.
Yeah, it was of epic proportions.
And after, basically I lost everything.
So after I fled from that place.
Ooh, people were so, I gotta tell you,
people were pretty thrilled that
now maybe Cassie will
be off her high horse.
I didn't know I was on
such high hours really.
And come to find out my
dealer's been sent away
on a mandatory vacation in jail.
Of course, as soon as I got out
the first thing I wanted to do was use,
but I had learned some
stuff in rehab about cavy
and what words to use and
possibly how to go to score
which I had been ignorant of.
I gave up my apartment
to go to this place
thinking I needed a whole fresh new start.
So when I get out,
I ended up staying with an old boyfriend.
But I go down,
I started to travel down
towards the Skid Row area.
And I think I had like
150 bucks in my pocket.
I'm a bit of (indistinct).
But I get to Alvarado.
They looked at me like I'm crazy.
By the time I get down to
Fifth and Broadway, you know,
I mean, I think this is just
the most horrible place,
and this is as far as I've ever been.
But now I'm down to what, like $60?
Because I'm giving someone
10 bucks to show me where
like the dub is.
I don't know if it's dub, dub, you know?
And I see, I meet this guy and he says,
"You know, I don't use drugs anymore,
"but you're gonna need a line,
I'll show you where it is."
So it's a foggy memory, but
he takes me down to Skid Row.
I score some drugs.
And which, I think I had
money enough for a dime.
He waits for me outside of
his tent that he allowed,
that he, I guess rented for
me so I can smoke my heroin,
and gets on the bus with me.
And he's an African-American man.
I never dated a black man before.
I never really had any experience of that.
But he pulls some money
out of his pocket and says,
"Oh, I'm for real, can I
get your phone number?"
And it was kind of awkward
and kind of gauche,
but also boyish and sweet.
And I look at him and I think,
"Man, you know, I really don't want to
"get the esoteric check for this one."
I think he must be like 26 years old.
Come to find out he was much older, but.
I said I would take his
number and consider it.
Well, it was on and cracking, you know?
So I started smoking crack and, ah,
and smoking heroin,
and now I'm not in my own place anymore.
The delivery guy isn't there, you know?
The left hand suddenly knows
what the right hand is doing.
Long story short, Andrew
comes back to catch me
in bed with another man.
Me and Andrew, I don't know, wow,
that sounded so much less
embarrassing in my head.
Ah, man.
Mind you, we were not
boyfriend-girlfriend,
but I do think there's really,
that's goes against Miss Manners for sure.
And that it really is not,
and it's not a good thing,
good or bad thing, bad.
Yeah, not good, not good.
So I ended up calling
this person that I met
and he comes and rescues me.
And I started, I'm staying at a hotel.
Like not quite a crack hotel,
but like a really crappy hotel.
You know, I mean,
I used to stay at the
Bristol in Paris, right?
This is for reference, come on, you know?
You know, that was a billion mile fall.
People have been waiting
for this billion mile fall.
I ended up following him down here.
And I was in the first
week of being down here.
He gave me a black eye,
almost knocked me out cold.
I thought a plane had fallen,
I went through the roof.
It was nine in the morning.
And what hurt the most
was I was smiling at him.
He said, he thought I was laughing at him.
He had been sober when I met him,
but quickly started smoking crack with me.
So I found a place to hide out
and I felt I was trying to decide
if I wanted to live or die.
And it's kinda been Shawshank
Redemption time ever since.
I feel embarrassed about the whole thing.
And I felt like it was the last place
anyone would ever look for me.
And I thought I could fix it by myself.
And I'll end it with this.
People always say,
"God never gives you more
than anything you can handle."
Right?
I think you were saying
something like that.
So to my understanding the
crux of the Bible is free will.
This might seem like a non-sequitur,
but in any language, on any
planet, in any vampire story,
a vampire cannot enter
unless they ask permission.
So that's the front and
the back of the matter.
The only thing that I've figured out
from these last, and it's, I have been,
I saw this over two-and-a-half years ago.
If I lied about it, I apologize.
I mean, I've done things since then.
This is all so embarrassing.
But the only thing I've learned is that
manners are the most
important thing to me.
And also that I really didn't
need to learn this lesson.
- [Mark] Okay, Cassandra,
thank you very much for
sharing this amazing story.
I'd love to have you back
again, we'll do it again.
Because I think there's a lot more of it.
- Yes.
- [Mark] This'll be part one.
- Okay.
- [Mark] When you're
ready, you're coming back.
- Okay.
- [Mark] All right.
- Thank you, Mark.
- [Mark] Thank you.